and finally new rule if you believe in
the philosophy of equality of outcomes
then you really shouldn't have watched
the grammys last sunday
because the grammys aside from the usual
award show virtue signaling
are still largely about the idea that
certain people do music
better than others and it's okay to
reward them for it
that's called meritocracy and it's the
opposite of guaranteed outcomes
equality of outcomes as opposed to
equality of opportunity
we used to call that by another name
trophy syndrome
a world that was
a world that was created back in the 90s
where everybody every kid gets a trophy
no matter how good or bad they are at
something
well the result of that kind of thinking
is that american kids now have a totally
deluded and unearned belief in their
charm brains and talent
it's not only that the entire generation
wants to be famous
it's that they think not being famous
isn't fair
if you think i'm exaggerating let me
quote from this article in rolling stone
magazine last year lamenting how
streaming has not given us equality of
outcomes in the music industry oh the
grammys would look quite different
if we followed this template the article
tells us that more than 1.6
million million artists
released songs between january 2019
and july 2020 40 000 tracks a day
on spotify and yet rolling stone
complains
today's streaming landscape looks a lot
like the music industry used to
a small class of artists see not just
the majority of activity but damn near
all of it
yes these are called the good ones
[Applause]
i mean yes of course an occasional big
talent can fall through the cracks but
in general it's simply a case that
most people who try their hand at music
write the songs that don't make the
whole world sing
rolling stone complains that quote
nearly all the streams went to artists
in the top 10 percent with the bottom 90
pulling in just 0.6 percent of streams
whoa
let me get this straight talented
artists people like
or listen to more than untalented ones
they don't
stop the presses yes that's meritocracy
if people don't like your song your
mommy can't make them listen to it
you know
you know why 99 of artists aren't
getting heard because music is hard and
most people suck at it
for more details google reality
rolling stone actually writes the
sentence in a perfect world the bottom
one percent of artists would get one
percent of activity
no they wouldn't that's a stupid world i
don't want to live in who taught you
this nonsense
and when you whine that streaming hasn't
just upheld the gap between music's
halves and have-nots
it's widened it you're making my case
for me because streaming allows the
public to sample
everybody there's no more gatekeepers
you can't complain no one heard your
song because no label would sign you
we tore that wall down and the result
was the same
some musicians are have-nots because yes
they may have a voice
but we have ears
it it reminds me of the early audition
rounds of the old american
idol where contestants are all attitude
and image
as if to say can we not focus so much on
the talent and just
skip the part to where the part i'm
going to get to be an idol
72 percent of gen z say they'd like to
be an
online celebrity and 54 percent of gen z
and millennials say they would become an
influencer
given the opportunity
you know if it wasn't too much work like
making a sex state
speaking of which
paris hilton just made
just made a return to the limelight
revealing that the ditzy party girl we
knew back in the day was just her
playing a character
and that there really was more to her
than sex tapes driving drunk carrying
around a little dog and saying that's
hot
i mean what about her work on the human
genome project
you know what any jokes i did about
paris i don't feel bad
sorry not sorry i i just can't i i can't
be living in this time
when we're madly on the hunt for
anything with the slightest whiff of
white privilege
and then feel bad for paris hilton
quite the reverse maybe paris is the one
who owes us an apology
for being patient zero for today's
vapid entitled famous for nothing
culture
she kind of birthed the world where
every 15 year old with the phone aspires
to be an influencer
she's the face that launched a thousand
little shits
[Applause]
paris led directly to the kardashians
and then to housewives and teen moms and
heidi's and snookies and a
generation of young girls who look up to
the role models who managed to turn an
unenthusiastic [ __ ] into an empire
young people who think talent my talent
is being me
and you wanting to live my life kylie
jenner is a billionaire based on her
ability to sit near a pool
for the generations who are always on
and on about this is my voice and i have
something to say
an awful lot of that something is about
lip gloss
you